हेलो फ्रेंड्स वेलकम तू अवर युटुब चैनल
अकादमी मेरा नाम है आयुष पाठक और मैं आपको
आज यहां पर नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की अगली
लेक्चर जो है अगली सीरीज जो है वह पढ़ना
जा रहा हूं ठीक है तो आपको ऑलरेडी पता है
की d6 तक ए चुकी है और इसको आए 9 दिन हो
चुका है देख सकते हैं ऑलरेडी तो सबसे पहले
तो मैं माफी चाहूंगा लेट होने के लिए कुछ
मेरे भी पर्सनल रीजंस है जिसके वजह से मैं
बीजी हो गया था और वीडियो अपलोड नहीं हो
का रही थी पर जान सके अब रेगुलर रहेंगे
वीडियो तो आप लोग मैं उम्मीद करता हूं
जितनी वीडियो पहले ए चुकी है और जितने
उनके टास्क है वो कंप्लीट कर चुके हैं
क्योंकि अगर आपने वो नहीं किया होंगे तो
आपको आगे की वीडियो समझ में नहीं आएगी ठीक
है तो नवीन करता हूं की पुरानी तस्कर
वीडियो अपने कंप्लीट कर लिए होंगे अब आगे
बढ़ते हैं हम लोग दे सेवन पे ठीक है चलिए
तो लास्ट में ट्रैक भी ओपन कर लेट हूं
टाइपिंग में हम लोग यहां पर मौजूद रहे
और जूस में आता हूं
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी अलार्म
उसके बड़े में आपको बताऊंगा पहले इसके बाद
हमको आगे बढ़ेंगे ठीक है तो पहले वही बात
कर लेते हैं की वो सब क्या होता है ठीक है
चलिए तो नाइट्रेट में उसे करना है आपको
ऑलरेडी बताया था इसमें मैं यहां पर दूध
लाइनेक्स के टर्मिनल खोल दे रहा हूं ठीक
है ये वसल है ठीक है विंडोज सिस्टम पर
इसमें ये काली ये एक तरीके से ठीक है तो
जैसे यहां पर दो अलग-अलग सिस्टम है इसमें
ये एक ही सिस्टम है पर मैंने दो ओपन कर
लिया है ठीक है दो टाइप उसका मां लीजिए
यहां पर मैं लिखना हूं नेट क्या है ठीक है
दास एन वे ल पी लास्ट टाइम मैंने आपको
इसका मतलब समझाया था
यहां पर ये रिलेशन कर रहा है ठीक है पोर्ट
नंबर फोर कर रहा है ये और मैं इस वाले से
कनेक्ट करूंगा तो मैं करूंगा रेड कैट फिर
उसका आईपी लिखूंगा मैं ठीक है
मुझे कनेक्ट करना है हमें इंटर करूंगा ये
देखिए यहां पर कनेक्शन
अब मैं यहां पे जो खेलूंगा मैं लिखना हूं
तो वहां पर जाएगा और मैं अगर यहां पर कुछ
लिखना हूं
यहां पर भी रखना हूं आयुष तो वो चीज आपको
यहां पर रिफ्लेक्टर होगी ठीक है अगर ये तू
वे कम्युनिकेशन के लिए ओपन हो चुका है तो
अब पहले आपको सेल्फ लेकर देखेंगे ठीक है
यहां पर आपको ओपन दिखता हूं अगर इमेज मिल
जाए तो
बढ़िया कोई मिल जाएगी सबको
एक एक ही इमेज में दोनों चीज मिल जाए
ठीक है हालांकि कुछ खास नहीं है इधर साइड
क्या है लेफ्ट साइड आपका यहां पर है ठीक
है और राइट साइड आपका है टारगेट सर्वर
टारगेट मतलब जिसका आपको हैक करना है
एक्चुअली में ठीक है अब बयान शैली में
क्या होता है बेन शैली में जो अटैकर होता
है ठीक है अटैक कर लेफ्ट हैंड जो बैठा हुआ
है सॉरी
जो ट्रैक्टर है वह कनेक्ट करता है किसको
अपने विक्टिम पर अपने टारगेट करता है
सामने से और रिवर्सल में क्या होता है
आपका जो व्यक्ति होता है वह आपको कनेक्ट
करता है अब ये कनेक्ट करने का मतलब क्या
है कनेक्ट करने का मतलब ये है की अगर आपके
अटैकर और विक्टिम पे मतलब विक्टिम को
एक्सेस करना है विक्टिम को आपको हैक करना
है ठीक है एथिकली तो अगर आपको दोस्तों हैक
करना है तो आपको ये चीज है ना की आप उसका
मतलब कोई भी कमांड आपकी शुरू करें वो
कमांड सिस्टम पे जाए वहां से आउटपुट
जेनरेट हो वो आउटपुट आपके पास ए जाए ठीक
है जैसे मैं यहां पर अपना कमांडो बैंड कर
रहा हूं और मैं वहां लीजिए लिखना हूं कोई
भी कमांड इसमें आईपी कॉन्फ़िगर लिख देता
हूं तुझे आउटपुट आया है यही चाहिए मुझे की
मैं अपने सिस्टम पे आईपी कम से भी लिखूं
या आईपी कनफ्लिक्ट दूसरे यानी
उसे तक ये कमांड पहुंचे मेरी वहां पर उसका
आउटपुट जेनरेट हो आपको जेनरेट होती है
मुझे मिल जाए तो नेटवर्क चालू होगा तभी तो
ये पॉसिबल हो पाएगा मतलब मेरे और नेटवर्क
होना चाहिए ठीक है एक कनेक्शन होना चाहिए
हमें उससे उसको हमें कनेक्ट करना पड़ेगा
तभी वो मैसेज जो है एक्सचेंज हो पाएगा ठीक
है तो ये दोनों तरीके से पॉसिबल है जैसे
मैंने आपको दिखाए है की यहां पर जो मैंने
कनेक्शन किया था मतलब ये दो डिवाइस में
कनेक्ट किया था दोनों तरफ से कम्युनिकेशन
इंपॉसिबल है ठीक है मतलब एक आदमी क्या
भेजेगा कमांड भेजेगा दूसरा आदमी संस्कृत
के आउटपुट भेजेगा
प्रोसेस टारगेट सिस्टम पे होना चाहिए
क्योंकि हम कमांड भेजेंगे उसे कमांड जो
प्रोसेस होगी और फिर जनरेटर का ऑर्बिट
हमें मिल जाएगा ठीक है अब यहां पर ये
सामने से कनेक्ट करने और पीछे से कनेक्ट
करने का मतलब क्या है इसका मतलब ये है की
एक तरीका ये है की हमारा जो टारगेट है
मतलब हम देखिए हमें एक सॉफ्टवेयर एक
एप्लीकेशन है एक कोड अपने त्रिदेव को
भेजना होता है जो मेरा वायरस होता है चाहे
वो मेटाफोर्स से बनाया है चाहे खुद से
कोडिंग करके बनाया है कैसे बनाएं ठीक है
हमें वो चीज अपने को भेजनी होती है सारे
करण होता है तो वहां पे उसका सिस्टम हैक
होता है लेकिन होता क्या है वहां पर एक
कनेक्शन होता है ठीक है तो दो तरीके से
होता है पहले ये जो आपका टारगेट है ठीक है
ये आपका टारगेट राइट में बैठा हुआ है ठीक
है वो लिसनिंग स्टार्ट कर दे क्या मतलब
कुछ इस तरीके से ठीक है
मतलब ये आपका मतलब इस साइड आपका टारगेट है
मां लीजिए ठीक है
दास और वीएलपी डायग्राम
मतलब ये हमें कनेक्ट करेगी
एक कैसे में टारगेट लेसन कर रहा होगा हम
कनेक्ट करेंगे दूसरे कैसे में हमने टायर
कनेक्ट कर रहा होगा तो जब टारगेट कर रहा
होगा हम कनेक्ट कर रहे होंगे ऊपर अलग है
उसको बैंड छल कहा जाता है और अब हम नहीं
सुन कर रहा होगा तो रिवर्सल का ए जाता है
क्योंकि वो रिवर्स हो रहा है देखिए अरा
बनाया सब समझ सकते हैं डिफरेंस क्या आता
है डिफरेंस नहीं आता है एक जगह आपको ओवर
दे इंटरनेट है कैसे भी आपको किसी सिस्टम
का मतलब कनेक्शन लेना है ठीक है अगर आप
इशाल इस्तेमाल करते हैं मतलब आपने क्या
किया आपने टारगेट पे लिसनिंग चालू कर दी
टारगेट रिलेशन कर रहा है आप अपने सिस्टम
से
कनेक्ट कर रहे हैं तो इसमें प्रॉब्लम ये ए
जाएगी की पहले बात तो सबसे बड़ी बात ये
होती है की जो आपका टारगेट है उसका आईपी
चेंज हो सकता है खाने का मतलब वो अपना
डॉक्टर बैंड करके ऑन करता है उसका आईपी
चेंज हो जाएगा ठीक है और दूसरा वो अपने
कुछ कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चेंज करता है उसका आईपी
चेंज हो जाएगा तो आपको हर बार उसको नया आए
थे मालूम कैसे चलेगा
आपको हर रोज का नया आइटम मालूम होना चाहिए
की अगर आप सामने से कनेक्शन भेजते हैं तो
वो मलेशिया भी लगता है ठीक है कैबिनेट
कनेक्शन क्यों भेज रहा है
कर शक्ति है इसलिए
क्या
फर्क नहीं पड़ता है आपको क्या करना है
आपको उसको एक मालवेयर भेजना है अपना ठीक
है उसे मालवेयर में आपका यानी आपके टेकन
मशीन का आईपी जो है हार्डकोर होगा उसमें
आपका हेल्पफुल होगा और आपका टारगेट सर्वर
ही आपके आईपी कनेक्ट करेगा तो आपका आईपी
तो आप फिक्स हो सकते हैं ना आप चाहे
स्ट्रेटजी कैसे भी करिए आप तो अपना कर
सकते हैं की वो चेंज हो तो आपका जो फिक्स
रहेगा ठीक है आपका टारगेट का चाहे जो भी
ईपू कितनी बैंड करके ऑन करें कोई भी चेंज
कर दो जब वो इंटरनेट पे ऑनलाइन होगा या
अपने नेटवर्क ऑनलाइन होगा जब वो कनेक्ट
करेगा तो आपके कनेक्ट हो जाएगा तो आपको
लिसनिंग करनी है ऐसे में क्या होगा अगर
आपका टैकल ही कनेक्शन को इनीशिएट कर रहा
है तो शेर भी नहीं लगेगा फायर बाल को
क्योंकि आपका मशीन खुद ही उसे कलेक्शन कर
रहा है आप उससे कनेक्ट नहीं कर रहा है वो
आपसे कनेक्ट हो रहा है इसीलिए यूनिवर्स
शेर का जो है फायदा होता है तो हमें क्या
उसे करते रिवर्सल उसे करते हैं
लिसनिंग चालू करनी है सॉरी हमें अपने
सिस्टम पे लिसन चालू करनी है ठीक है ना
ये मेरा सिस्टम है
अटैक कर क्या करेगा लिसनिंग चालू कर देगा
33 ठीक है इस पर क्लिक करना है 444 में
लिसनिंग यहां पर चालू है ठीक है चलोगे
यहां पे रिक्त करना है और यहां पर मैं दे
दूंगा क्या टेस्ट आई / बिन स्लैश दास तो
इंटर कर देता हूं अब ये देखिए ये यहां पर
अटैक का मशीन है मैं लिखना हूं भाई मिल
गया मुझे ठीक है यहां पर क्या हुआ मैंने
क्या किया
इस वाले से मैंने कनेक्ट किया और मैंने
अपनी प्रोसेस वाली अब यहां से जो भी जो भी
यहां पर भेजूंगा ठीक है वो यहां पर आकर
प्रोसेस होगा क्योंकि इस तरह से होगा इससे
प्रोसेस होगा आपको जो निकाल के आएगा वो
हमें सेंड हो जाएगा काली ठीक है इस तरह
मैं लिखना हूं आईडी देखिए ठीक है जो भी
अपने यहां पर कर रहा हूं ए जाएगा मेरे पास
तो ये हमारा कौन सा मशीन है ये हमारा टेकन
मशीन है जिसके हम रिजनिंग कर रहे थे
ये हमारा विक्टिम है और ये हमारा पेड़ है
इसी पीरियड हमने सॉरी ये वाला पीरियड है
इसके जारी हमने इसको हैक किया है सिस्टम
को हैक किया है ठीक है तो यही पेरोड अगर
आप किसी लाइनेक्स मशीन में जिसमें राकेट
चालू है उसका भेज देते हैं यहां पर अपना
आईपी दाल के और अपना आईपीएस चालू किया है
आपने तो गूगल सिस्टम आपको कंट्रोल में ए
जाएगा तो वो खैर आगे भी चीज है की कैसे
पीरियड बंता है जो सेल्फ कॉन्सेप्ट था वो
इस तरीके से आप पता था रिवर्स साइड ठीक है
तो जाना जरूरी था आपके लिए मैंने आपको ये
बता दिया की यूनाइटेड बड़े में हमने पढ़
ही लिया था पर ये नहीं देखा था तो मैंने
आपको ये भी समझा दिया अच्छे से ठीक है मैं
करता हूं आपको समझ में ए गया होगा कोई
कन्फ्यूजन नहीं होगी
चलिए
क्या बात कर लिया की पैसे भी कॉन्शांइस
कैसे कर रहा है किसी को मतलब की उससे बिना
इंटरेक्ट किया ठीक है
अब हम बात करने वाले हैं की नेटवर्क में
कोई डिस्कवरी कैसे करना है
तो वो ऑनलाइन है की नहीं है और उसमें
फर्ज है एनीमेशन भारत
नेटवर्क चार्ज
बात कर लेते हैं इसकी बड़े में आप लोग
100% जानती ही होंगे नेटवर्क टूल होता है
ये ठीक है काफी नंबर से कलीम में पहले से
आता है काली भी हमने चालू कर लेते हैं
इसका कर सकते हैं इसका जो है ग्राफिकल अभी
आता है ज़ेन कहते हैं अगर मेरे इंस्टॉल
इंस्टॉल है ठीक है
अपना खाली ऑन कर लेट हूं
इसमें हम क्या पढ़ने वाले हैं की एन में
का इस्तेमाल करके कैसे जो है लाइव ह्यूज
डिस्कवरी करते हैं मतलब यहां पर बहुत सारे
इतने सारे इसमें है क्या अलग-अलग
टेक्निक्स होती है ठीक है अलग-अलग
टेक्निक्स में क्यों पढ़ने हैं इसके बड़े
में भी हम समझेंगे तो भाई एक तरीका के ऊपर
रहे हैं हम लोग ठीक है और आपको जरूरी नहीं
है इसी तरीके से याद रखना की जरूर नहीं
होती है समझ लीजिए एक बार ताकि आपको उसका
जो है पूर्व कौन से पता रहेगा ठीक है चलिए
इंट्रोडक्शन
ठीक है ये आर पी का इस्तेमाल करते हैं हम
लोग एड्रेस रेजोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल के बड़े
में आपको बताया था मैंने ऑलरेडी एमपी के
सवाल करते हैं
यहां पर
आगे बढ़ते हैं
आपको ठीक है ये सब नेटवर्क्स इसमें कहां
से ए गया सो नेटवर्क्स में आने का रीजन ये
है की आपको जो नेटवर्क स्कैनिंग करनी है
वो अपने नेटवर्क के अंदर करनी है इस टाइप
में नेटवर्क के बाहर कर दिए खाने का मतलब
क्या है कैप्टन नेटवर्क सब नेटवर्क हो
सकते हैं
ऑलरेडी है ये डायग्राम हो सकते हैं इसको
ठीक है और वो होता है की आपका नेटवर्क
मतलब आपको जो स्कैनिंग करनी है वो अपने
सबमिट के अंदर करनी है की दूसरे सब
नेटवर्क्स में भी करनी है और इंटरनेट पर
कोई डिवाइस अवेलेबल है उसे पे करनी है ठीक
है
इसीलिए यहां पर बताया गया है तो सब
नेटवर्क्स क्या होते हैं सब
नेटवर्क से बताया था ठीक है
ठीक है पर आपको यहां पर लिखा हुआ है की
अगर आपको मतलब
कम ये होता है की जैसे आप कोई नेटवर्क के
अंदर है ठीक है और आपको किसी भी ऐसे
कम्युनिकेट करता है करना है तो लैंड के
अंदर तो आईपी एड्रेस और मैक्रोज
कम्युनिकेशन होता है ठीक है तो आप क्या
करते हैं यहां पे केयर पे रिक्वेस्ट भेजते
हैं मां लीजिए आपको यहां पर
मां लीजिए आपको क्या करना है आपको
192.168 में जूम कर देता हूं गठबंधन 35 से
कांटेक्ट करना है तो आप क्या करेंगे आप एक
इआरपी रिक्वेस्ट भेजेंगे ठीक है ए आर पी
रिक्वेस्ट रिक्वेस्ट क्या रहेगी
ये आपने क्या कर दी ब्रॉडकास्ट कर दी ठीक
है अब जी डिवाइस के पास विप था उसने
रिप्लाई किया की आई हैव
192.168.1.35 ठीक है
आपने क्या किया ब्रॉडकास्ट किया मतलब आपने
अपने पैकेट को अपने नेटवर्क के अंदर
अवेलेबल है इसको सेंड कर दिया था की जिसके
पास वो रिप्लाई कर दे लेकिन ये सेंड ये
ब्रॉडकास्ट कहां तक होता है आपके
से सबने तक होगा खाने का मतलब यह आपका
नेटवर्क इंटरनेट पे मिल जाएगा तो उसे
इंटरनेट नहीं जाएगा ठीक है तो आप आरपी का
इस्तेमाल करके अपने नेटवर्क के अंदर ही
क्या कर सकते हैं चेक कर सकते हैं तो इससे
आपका प्रूफ हो जाएगा कौन सा ऑनलाइन है की
नहीं समझ रहे होंगे आप जो ऑनलाइन होगा वो
रिप्लाई करेगा ठीक है तो ये तरीका हो सकता
है लेकिन आपका यहां पर इंपॉर्टेंट ये है
की आप ये अपने ट्रक के अंदर ही कर सकते
हैं आप उसको अब इंटरनेट पे आपने नेटवर्क
के बाहर नहीं कर सकते ठीक है ये ध्यान
रखना वाली चीज थी यही पॉइंट यहां पर दिया
हुआ है अब ये मैंने क्यों बताया है अभी आप
आगे समझ जाएंगे चलिए
कर लेट हूं पहले तेरे लिए ओपन हो गया ठीक
है
कंप्यूटर वन कंप्यूटर तू कंप्यूटर
से कनेक्ट है
सेंड करते हैं
आपको कंप्यूटर वन से यहां पर
ठीक है
आगे बढ़ते हैं क्या यहां पर
क्या था
ब्रॉडकास्ट के लिए ठीक है मतलब कंप्यूटर
से कंप्यूटर वन का मतलब ब्रॉडकास्ट था ठीक
है की ताकि ब्रॉडकास्ट है
कंप्यूटर से इसका मैक एड्रेस ठीक है
कंप्यूटर सिक्स इस पे तो है नहीं रिप्लाई
कोई आया नहीं क्योंकि वो जो कंप्यूटर में
से इनीशिएट हो गया वो सिर्फ कंप्यूटर तू
कंप्यूटर थ्री और आउटपुट हो जाएगा इसके
आगे नहीं बाढ़ पाएगा अगर देखिए
कंप्यूटर से दूसरे से नेटवर्क पे है उसका
रिप्लाई नहीं आएगा देखिए हो में डिवाइस
कर डिवाइस वन तू थ्री फोर करेंगे
देखिएगा
ब्रॉडकास्ट हुआ कंप्यूटर
से रिप्लाई
किया हां दोस्तों मिला है ठीक है ये आपने
समझ लिया एप्लीकेशन कैसे कम कर रहा है अलग
से नेटवर्क में सिर्फ कम कर रहा है
इसका इआरपी रिक्वेस्ट ब्रॉडकास्ट दूसरे से
नेटवर्क में नहीं जाएगा या फिर इंटरनेट पे
नहीं जाएगा ठीक है ये हमने इसके लिए पढ़ा
है क्योंकि नेक्स्ट हम लोग पढ़ने वाले हैं
कुछ डर में या फिर से आईडेंटिफाई करने
वाला ठीक है मतलब यार किसी किस तरीके से
हमें नोटिफिकेशन करना है पोस्ट की इसलिए
हमने ये पढ़ा है अभी चलिए मैं बात कर लेते
हैं
सवाल करके हम लोग इस तरीके से कर सकते हैं
पहले आपको मैं करके दिखता हूं
बेसिक मतलब
इस तरीके से स्टोरी कर सकते हैं देखिए
यहां पर एक डिवाइस
आगे बढ़ते हैं
अभी आगे ठीक है
खाने का मतलब क्या है आपको मैं मतलब अगर
आप यहां पर कुछ इस तरीके से लिखने हैं अगर
की और मैप दास एस ल ठीक है
192.168.1.04 तो ये तो आप देख के समझ सकते
हैं ऐसे इसको देख के आप जल्दी समझ जा रहा
है ना की क्या यहां पर 192.1 0 से लेक 100
तक सारे बनेंगे क्योंकि स्टैंडर्ड है
लेकिन अगर यही थोड़ा अजीब सा लिखा होता है
ये सब मतलब यहां पर 19 लिखा होता तो आप
यहां पर बताते हैं कितना होने वाला है
इसका कैलकुलेशन बहुत दिक्कत हो जाति है
ठीक है पता ना पाते डायरेक्टली ऐसे ही आप
इस चीज का इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं
आने वाले हैं ठीक है
आने वाले हैं ये आपको बता देगा ठीक है समझ
में ए जाएगा आपको
चलिए
हमें इसको स्कैन करना है इस नेटवर्क को
ओपन कर देता हूं मैं हमेशा नेटवर्क को
स्कैन करना है
की वो आईपी एड्रेस ऑन नहीं थे फॉलोइंग
आप इस तरीके से आपको
168.1.035 अब इस तरीके से दे सकते हैं
मतलब लास्ट वाले ऑक्टेंट में ये साड़ी
वैल्यू देख लो आप ऐसे भी सकते हैं की जीरो
से 25 तक सारे आईपी एड्रेस कर लो जीरो से
10 तक सारे वीडियो कर लो यू नो टेंशन होता
है ठीक है ना तो अगर आप यहां पर देखा हूं
मैं 101 से 125 तक ठीक है ये कितना हो
जाएगा आपका 1015 एक्स एक से 200 सॉरी हां
25 ही है ना 200 नहीं है ठीक है चाहे आपके
नो इधर हो जाएंगे ठीक है 15 हो जाएगा मतलब
आपके यहां पर 25 टोटल हनी चाहिए ना
चाहिए
ठीक है तो एक तो यहां पर एक हो जाएगा और
नो यहां पर 10 यहां पर हो जाएगा ठीक है
तो आपके 25 होना चाहिए
ओ सॉरी सॉरी गलती हो गई
नहीं दिया मैंने सिंपल ये देखिए
तो यहां पर क्या होगा यहां पर
बने वाले हैं ठीक है और जीरो से 250 के
यहां तक बने वाले हैं ठीक है जीरो से लेक
20 तक सारे चेक करने वाला है ये तो तू
जीरो करते हुए यहां पर 266 बन जाएगा 266
रन यहां पे बनेंगे ठीक है और यहां पे
कितने रेंज बनेंगे 25 रेंज यहां पर भी ठीक
है तो कितने हो गए 266 * 25
कर लेते हैं
यहां पे बनेंगे और आपके 25 यहां पर बनेंगे
बन गया 6000 से 50 650
से यहां बने वाले हैं
यार 2006 नहीं दोस्तों 56 होगा वही मेरा
हो रहा है सॉरी
कैलकुलेटर
256 256
मैंने कहा
6400 ठीक है 6000
तो 255 तो हो ही गया और जीरो भी इंक्लूड
होगा तो 256 हो गया 250 बनेंगे और यहां
कितने बनेंगे यहां पर यहां पर जीरो से
नहीं है तो 0 फुट नहीं होगा जैसे की यहां
पे 25 मिलेंगे तो हर एक यहां पे वैल्यू के
लिए 25% बनेगा यहां पे कितनी वैल्यू है
मेरा कितना आया 600 ठीक है यहां पर
कैसे करना है ठीक है
सेंड कर
सेंड पैकेज डी फॉलोइंग कंप्यूटर थिंक पिंक
पैकेट मेरे ख्याल से इसी वाले को करना है
हमें
करना है
कंप्यूटर वन से कंप्यूटर
भेजनी है
कंप्यूटर वन पिंक से पहले क्या भेजेगा
पिंक से पहले
दिया हुआ है
मैं फर्स्ट फिल्म सेंड कर रहा हूं देखिए
रिप्लाई
रिस्पांस मिलकर
रेस्पॉन्ड करेगा
व्हाट इसे डी नाम ऑफ डी फर्स्ट डिवाइस डेट
इस गोइंग तू डी आरपी रिक्वेस्ट
सॉरी
ऑलरेडी हो चुकी है
कंप्यूटर
पर कंप्यूटर
व्हाट इसे डी नाम ऑफ दोबारा मैसेज करूंगा
ठीक है
मुझे आपको समझ में कोई डाउट पूछ लीजिएगा
ठीक है सेंड अनदर थिंक रिक्वेस्ट
आई है अगर आप दोबारा थिंक करते हैं इसका
नया एप्लीकेशन पड़ेगी नहीं पड़ेगी ठीक है
देखने वाले हैं चलिए
कम कैसे करता है समझ गए होंगे अभी देखिए
क्या बंता है सबसे पहले और इंपॉर्टेंट बात
सेकंड चीज ट्रेंड्स तो चेंज होते रहेंगे
नेटवर्क आते जाएंगे आपको कॉन्सेप्ट पता
होना चाहिए कैसे कम कर रहा है जैसे कुछ
बेसिक चीज हैं जैसे की नॉन पे विलेज मोड
में और क्या उसे करता है क्या उसे करता है
लेकिन जरूरी नहीं है की आपको हमेशा याद हो
ठीक है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ये कोई
कॉन्सेप्ट नहीं है तो आपका जो है आप करते
रहेंगे दोस्तों आपको याद रहेगा तो देखो
दिक्कत नहीं है गूगल कर सकते हैं ठीक है
ये कैसे होता है वो आपको मेथड पता होना
चाहिए हम लोग मैन्युअल देखने वाले हैं
मेथड
लोकल नेटवर्क पे नहीं और इंटरनेट
कर रहे हैं
रूट है डायरेक्टली ठीक है तो आपका इआरपी
रिक्वेस्ट वाला मेथड उसे होता है ठीक है
व्हेन एन प्रिविलेज यूजर ट्राई तू स्कैन
ट्रेट आउटसाइड डी लोकल नेटवर्क अपने
नेटवर्क से बाहर करते हैं और यूजर्स
सीएमपी को रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है एसीपी
सर्टिफिकेट
उसे करता है ठीक है जो आप प्रीवियस दे रहे
हो आप आउट ऑफ स्कैन कर रहे हैं अरे
प्रिविलेज यूजर नहीं है ठीक है एंटरप्राइज
क्या है और अगर आप नेटवर्क के बाहर उसे कर
रहा है तो ये सिंपल सा पीपीपी थ्री वे
हंदशके बनाता है और चेक करता है ठीक है ना
चलिए दो-तीन तरीके हैं डिफॉल्ट वाले जैसे
आप सबसे कमांड नहीं देते हैं और उसमें मैप
से मतलब है की नहीं है वो सभी बैंक करता
है देखिए
स्कैन तू फाइंड लाइव होस्ट ठीक है
आईएफ यू वांट तू कर
करेगा
ये बताइए की जैसे अभी आपको यहां पर
स्टिमुलेशन भी देखा आपने सिमुलेशन
हुआ था ब्रॉडकास्ट हुआ था वो सिर्फ
नेटवर्क के अंदर ही गया था उसके बाद में
नहीं गया था ठीक है ना चलिए
स्कैन करके दिखता हूं
चलिए एनएफ करते हैं
सॉरी एयरपिस्ट कैन और हमें क्या किया
लिख देता हूं
ओके सो मेरे नेटवर्क कनेक्शन
छोड़ दिया है ठीक है तो इशू नहीं आएगा
कंटिन्यू करता हूं
यहां पर और देखिए
यहां पर क्या कर रहे हैं यहां पर
मिल रहे हैं ठीक है क्योंकि यार ये समझ गए
होंगे ये नेटवर्क के अंदर कम कर रहा है
ठीक है चलिए आगे बढ़ते हैं
डायनेमिक रिप्रेजेंटेशन की एप्लीकेशन ए
गया ठीक है अब ये कम कैसे कर रहा है ये
किस तरीके से कम कर रहा है की आपके पूरे
जैसे मां लीजिए अपने ये इसके अंदर किया था
ठीक है आपने ये स्कैन किया था इस तरीके से
इसका मतलब क्या था इसने क्या किया
192.168.1.0 से लेकर 25 तक सारे क्या किया
ब्रॉडकास्ट रिक्वेस्ट कर दिया ये भी
ब्रॉडकास्ट कर दिया है ठीक है इसको ब्रोकर
कर दिया हर एक आईपी के लिए अब जितने भी
अवेलेबल थे ट्राई कर दिया आपका समझ में ए
गया यहां पर अवेलेबल है ठीक है इसीलिए ये
सिर्फ नेटवर्क के अंदर कम करता है समझ गए
यहां पर दिया हुआ है मेरे ख्याल से की
फिल्म
ये भी से ही कम करता है आप यहां पर ये
एयरप्लेन
नेटवर्क स्कैन कर सकते हैं आप इंटरफेस भी
कर सकते हैं की आपको कौन से इंटरफेस स्कैन
करना है ठीक है तो मैं आपको करके दिखता
हूं इसे यहां पर लिखना हूं
ये ठीक है यहां पर लगा दीजिए मैं सेंटर कर
दीजिए इसको अमेरिका से ये दूसरा इंटरफेस
दे रहा है तो मैं इंटरफेस भी ये साइन कर
देता हूं
हैप्पी रिक्वेस्ट के सारे जितने वीडियो
अच्छे-अच्छे उनको डिटेक्टर कर लिया ठीक है
उसको कमांड से सॉल्व करना पड़ेगा तो कर
लेंगे
एफ ए कोटा
डिवाइस को ट्राई करना है ठीक है बात क्या
है यहां पर क्वेश्चन यू अबाउट डिस्कवरी
रिक्वेस्ट अगर कंप्यूटर से हम करते हैं तो
कंप्यूटर में तो काउंट करेंगे नहीं ठीक है
इसके अलावा क्या-क्या बच्चा है इसमें
नेटवर्क में बच्चा कंप्यूटर तू स्विच
कंप्यूटर
तू कंप्यूटर ठीक है तीन डिवाइस जो है पकड़
पाएंगे
नेक्स्ट यहां पर आता है
नेटवर्क
ठीक है तो अभी बात है इसका टाइप क्या होता
है 8 होता है ठीक है ना टाइप ए टी को होता
है ठीक है अर्जेंट रिप्लाई होता है वो
जीरो होता है चलिए ये तो बेसिक चीज है अब
इसके बड़े में कुछ खास नहीं है बस यहां पर
एक चीज लिखा हुआ है की कई बार ऐसा होता है
की फॉर्मल ब्लॉक करता है एमपी को जैसे
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट विंडोज ठीक है मतलब पिंक
करेंगे
पता नहीं कर पाएंगे क्योंकि ये आपको ध्यान
रखना है तो यहां पर दास कर सकते हैं दास
पी मतलब
सिंपल सी बात एकदम वही सब कुछ से तरीका है
ठीक है नॉर्मल आप यहां पर लिखिए सिंपल
राखी है
दिखा देगा देखिए ये एक्टिव है ये एक्टिव
है या फिर आपको इस तरीके से मिल जाएगा ठीक
है तो ये आपका शुरू हो गया है
एक और तरीका होता है मास्किंग लिखा होगा
ठीक है इसमें क्या होता है टाइप चेंज होता
है मतलब आपका टाइप ए जाता है ठीक है
रिप्लाई कैसा आता है टाइप 14 का आता है इस
तरीके से आपका और टाइप होता है यहां पर और
दिया होगा और जैसे यहां पर टाइप फाइटिंग
होता है 70 टाइप 70 ठीक है रिप्लाई टाइप
18 में आता है इसका अलग-अलग कर सकते हैं
इस वाले को इसको आप बेस्ट कर सकते हैं अगर
टेक्निकल एजुकेशन
व्हाट इसे डी ऑप्शन रिक्वायर
टीसीपी यूडीपी से क्या करना है इसमें कुछ
खास नहीं है नॉर्मल तरीके से भारत केयरिंग
टाइप ही करने वाले हैं इसमें ये गेम क्या
करते हैं यहां पर किसी भी
सिनेपिंग का इस्तेमाल ठीक है इसमें क्या
हुआ हमने सिंपल 39 की कोशिश की अगर बन गया
ठीक है ये क्या करता है में डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट
80 पे ठीक है ट्राई करता है ये करने का
ठीक है और अगर नीचे ए जाता है ठीक है
क्लोज स्पोर्ट रिजल्ट इन रिसेट दिस कैसे
वे कैन ओनली चेक वेदर वे बिल गेट दिस वन
खाने का मतलब ये है की अगर यहां पर कुछ
करते हैं अगर बन गया इसका मतलब सिस्टम
होगा अगर नहीं बंता है आर एस टी एफ लगता
है मतलब आर एस टी आता है मतलब सिस्टम चालू
है अगर रिप्लाई नहीं आता इसमें सिस्टम भी
डॉ है ठीक है मतलब सिस्टम चालू है
अगर आपको एक भेजना है
मतलब
रिप्लाई नहीं आया इसका मतलब सिस्टम बैंड
हो जाएगा सिस्टम चालू है ठीक है
ऊपर भी दिए हुए थे ऑलरेडी यहां पर किसी भी
सिम पी का इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं
ओपन ठीक है और अगर आपने भेजो ठीक है और
आपका रिस्पांस क्या आया यहां पर ये वीडियो
भी प्रोडक्ट्स क्लोज हो जाएगा
डेस्टिनेशन
देखा होगा डेस्टिनेशन ठीक है इसका मतलब
कोड क्या है क्लोज है और यहां पर इनकी
लाइफ
होगा की अगर पोर्ट यहां पर क्लोज है ठीक
है ये रिस्पांस आता है इसका मतलब जो है वो
लाइव है ठीक है मतलब क्लोज बटन
है वो लाइव है ठीक है इसके लिए आप दास का
स्वागत है
वहां भी रहेगी इस तरीके से एक और होता है
मास के लिए यार पीस के अंदर मास्क स्क्रीन
भी होता है इससे भी आप सिंपल मार्क्स के
लिए लिखकर मशीन की आईपी लिखकर कोड देकर
इस्तेमाल करता है मास के अंदर ठीक है
इस तरीके से प्यार कर सकते हैं
सारे प्रोडक्ट दे सकते हैं इस तरीके से
यहां पर आप पोस्ट करेंगे
ठीक है इसका कोई स्टॉक करना पड़ता है
अगर आपको सीधे
करके अपने में कस्टम
21 ठीक है
[संगीत]
ओ सॉरी
होता है
22 ठीक है सॉरी होता है
आपने देखा होगा आईपी के कॉरस्पॉडिंग में
होस्टिंग है
आपको डिसएबल नहीं करना है कस्टम डीएनए
सर्विस इस्तेमाल करना है आप ये वाला स्विच
देखिए यहां पर डीएनए का एड्रेस दे सकते
हैं ठीक है और दास आर दे सकते हैं
यानी का मतलब जो ऑफलाइन बता रहा है उसके
लिए अगर आपको नास रिवर्स डीएनए को ट्राई
करवाना है तो आप दशरथ ट्राई कर सकते हैं
तो देखिए वे वांट तू वे वांट nf2 इशू का
रिवर्स डीएस लुकअप पर जो डी पॉसिबल
कंप्लीट हो गया इसको अभिषेक कर दीजिए
एक बार
आपको डिफरेंस इतनी डिफरेंस
होती है ठीक है इस लेक्चर के रिकॉर्डिंग
जो भी पोस्ट होगी यहां पर
वो आपको उसमें कमेंट करना है ठीक है आपको
कैसा लगा
ठीक है चलिए यहां पर ये और हो गया नेक्स्ट
में हम लोग पढ़ने वाले हैं भारत करेंगे
कुछ टेक्निक्स के बड़े में कुछ चीज हम लोग
पढ़ेंगे जैसे पहले पढ़ेंगे फिर एडवांस
पढ़ेंगे बहुत सारे टाइप के भारत चैनल
भारत चैनल कैसे करना है वो भी हिंदू भाई
जो है पढ़ने वाले हैं आपका कंप्लीट हो
चुका है ठीक है यहां पर ए जाएगा अभी
तीन में हमारा कंप्लीट हो चुका है बाकी हम
यहां पर करने वाले हैं ठीक है तो जरूर
देगा हमारे वीडियो के साथ पूरे सीरीज के
साथ बढ़िया
थैंक यू मिलते नेक्स्ट वीडियो में